>> Sean: JAY SEKULOW,
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
LET ME EXPLAIN HOW IF WE GO TO
THE POLITICO ARTICLE, THE
PROBLEMS WITH JOE BIDEN ARE
SERIOUS HERE AND ESPECIALLY --
LOOK AT POLITICO 2017.
I HAVE THE COPYRIGHT HERE.
IF YOU LOOK AT IT.
I HAVE IT RIGHT HERE SOMEWHERE.
IT IS JANUARY 11TH AND IT IS
INTO 2017.
LET'S GO BACK AND READ FROM THIS
PARTICULAR ARTICLE BECAUSE THIS
GETS TO THE HEART OF EVERYTHING
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING AND WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE WRONG AND WHAT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE.
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
TRIED TO HELP HILLARY CLINTON
AND UNDERMINE TRANSIT BY
PUBLICLY QUESTIONING HIS FITNESS
FOR OFFICE.
THEY ALSO DISSEMINATED
DOCUMENTS, IMPLICATING A TOP
TRYING TO AID IN CORRUPTION AND
SUGGESTED THAT THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING THE MATTER ONLY TO
BACK AWAY AFTER THE ELECTION.
THEY HELD THE CLINTON'S ALLIES,
RESEARCH DAMAGING INFORMATION ON
TRUMP AND HIS ADVISORS.
WELL, IT CONTINUES TO MOUNT FOR
SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE.
RUDY GIULIANI IS WITH US.
FORMER NEW YORK CITY MAYOR.
I HAVE IS THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
YOU GO AND TAKE UP WITH CONGRESS
BECAUSE I BELIEVE JAY SEKULOW,
YOUR PARTNER, IS CORRECT.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY EXPERIENCE
IN A COURTROOM.
I GET NERVOUS PUBLIC SPEAKING
AND THESE PEOPLE ARE OF SUCH
INTELLECTUAL HEAVYWEIGHTS I
DON'T KNOW IF I CAN HANDLE IT.
>> Sean: WHILE HE WAS STILL A
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
UKRAINE ADMITTED THEY WERE DOING
ELECTION INTERFERENCE WITH THIS
COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT IN THIS CALL ASKED
THEM TO HELP GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF WHAT THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS
SAID THEY WANTED.
THEY ARE NOT DOING IT.
>> SEAN, YOU JUST LAID OUT THE
REASON WHY I WAS INVESTIGATING
AND THE REASON WHY THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES HAD
OBLIGATIONS TO ASK THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UKRAINE TO FOLLOW UP ON
THESE ALLEGATIONS.
THERE IS SUBSTANTIAL --
I DON'T WANT TO EXAGGERATE THE
PRETTY GLAZED TO OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE INCLUDING THE FINDING
BY UKRAINIAN COURT THAT
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE
DEMOCRATS COOPERATED WITH
UKRAINIANS WITH THE ORDER COMING
DIRECTLY FROM THE WHITE HOUSE IN
JANUARY OF 2017 TO DIG UP DIRT
ON HER POLITICAL OPPONENT AND
THEY DID.
I BET POLITICO REGRETS PRINTING
THAT ACTUALLY BECAUSE NOW THEY
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
COVER IT OUT BUT IN FACT, THEY
LAID OUT THE REASONS WHY IF I
DID IT INVESTIGATE IT, I WOULD
BE GUILTY OF MALPRACTICE.
THEY SEEM TO FORGET THAT I AM A
LAWYER.
IF I WERE DEFENDING A TERRORIST,
THEY WOULD BE GOING CRAZY THAT I
WAS CALLED BEFORE A SENATE
COMMITTEE.
ALTHOUGH CIVIL LIBERTIES GROUPS
WOULD SAY RIGHT TO COUNSEL BEER
AND HOW CAN THEY INTIMIDATE A
LAWYER?
IT'S FEARLESS PURSUIT OF TRYING
TO DEFY JUSTICE.
I WAS NOT INVOLVED AT ANY
ELECTION AS ANYTHING.
THIS STARTED TWO YEARS BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
IT STARTED AND ENDED PRETTY MUCH
BEFORE THE MUELLER PROBE WAS
OVER.
I WAS STILL GATHERING EVIDENCE
TO PROVE HIS INNOCENCE AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN I REALIZE THAT THERE
WAS A FRAME UP, DELIBERATE ONE,
OF THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT AND THAT A COLOSSAL
PAY FOR PLAY SCHEMES AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THAT WAS EERILY
SIMILAR TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION COMPLETELY CORRUPT
BEHAVIOR IN WHICH THE CLINTONS
SOLD HER OFFICE OF SECRETARY OF
STATE AS FOR MILLIONS.
IS THERE ANYBODY THAT BELIEVES
THAT UKRAINE OR CHINA WERE
PAYING FOR HUNTER BIDEN'S
EXPERTISE OR DO YOU HAVE THE
COMMON SENSE TO REALIZE THEY
WERE BUYING THE JOE BIDEN'S
OFFICE?
THAT IS VERY DAMAGING TO THE
UNITED STATES.
JOE BIDEN WAS SENT TO UKRAINE TO
IMPART DEAL WITH CORRUPTION AND
HE HELPED TO CORRUPT THE
UKRAINE.
HE IS A LAUGHINGSTOCK.
WE ARE TO BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT
CORRUPTION AND THIS GUY PUTS
HIS INCOMPETENT SON TO WORK FOR
THE MOST CROOKED OLIGARCH IN
RUSSIA.
I MEAN, IT IS OUTRAGEOUS.
THE ONLY REALLY SAD PART OF THIS
IS HOW MUCH IN THE TANK AND HOW
CORRUPT THIS MEDIA HAS BECOME.
THEY HAVE CORRUPTION STARING
THEM IN THE FACE AND THEY CLOSED
THEIR EYES TO IT AND THEN THEY
MAKE UP CHARGES AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT AREN'T
TRUE.
OR THEY DON'T LOOK AT THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
HE IS GIVING A HEARSAY EVIDENCE.
THE THING IS FILLED WITH I DON'T
KNOW, I HEARD IT, I OVERHEARD,
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE TIME HE
SAYS I KNOW.
YESTERDAY I PRODUCED A WITNESS
WHO IS UNDER OATH.
HE IS WILLING TO GIVE HIS NAME,
HE IS WILLING TO TESTIFY.
MAYBE ONE OF OUR REPUBLICANS IN
THE SENTENCE COULD CALL HIM.
HE IS THE GUY THAT BIDEN FIRED.
HE IS THE GUY THAT WILL TESTIFY
UNDER OATH.
HE WILL FACE BIDEN AND SAY YOU
CORRUPTED MY COUNTRY.
IT YOU GOT ME FIRED ON FALSE
PRETEXT AND THEN YOU HAD THE
CASE AGAINST A CORRUPT COMPANY
DISMISSED AND I'M GOING TO TELL
YOU ONE OTHER THING, BIDEN'S
CORRUPTION HELPED TO COVER UP
ALL OF THE ALLEGATIONS OF
COLLUSION BECAUSE THERE WAS A
COMPANY INVOLVED RUN BY
GEORGE SOROS WHO WAS INVOLVED IN
THE INVESTIGATION AND THAT WAS
CLOSED ON TO CUT OFF ALL OF THE
PROOFS, THE ADDITIONAL PROOF,
OF JUST HOW FAR THE DEMOCRATS
WENT IN THE 2016 ELECTION AND IN
CORRUPTING THE UKRAINE.
>> Sean: MR. MAYOR, THE
VICE PRESIDENT WAS PUT IN CHARGE
OF UKRAINE.
LET'S GO TO THE TIMELINE.
2014.
IT WAS ONLY MONTHS AFTERWARD.
WE CAN FIND NO EXPERIENCE IN
UKRAINE FOR HIS SON, NONE.
NO EXPERIENCE IN THE ENERGY
SECTOR, NONE.
>> HE HAD JUST BEEN THROWN OUT
OF THE NAVY.
HE WOULD PAY HIM MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO GO ON A COMPANY THAT
HAD TO BE REFORMED AND THE KID
GOT THROWN OUT OF THE NAVY AFTER
HIS FATHER PULLED STRINGS TO GET
HIM IN?
YOU GOT THROWN OUT TRAGICALLY I
GUESS FAILING A DRUG TEST BUT
CHINA DOESN'T PAY A GUY WHO
FAILS A DRUG TEST MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, BILLIONS, IN A PRIVATE
EQUITY FUND AND SURE AS HECK OF
A CROOKED OLIGARCH DOESN'T GUY
WHO'S DRUG CHALLENGE TO BE ON
HIS BOARD.
THEY BOUGHT JOE BIDEN'S OFFICE.
WAKE UP DEMOCRATS.
YOU ARE COVERING UP CORRUPTION
AND BY THE TIME AND IS OVER, YOU
ARE GOING TO BE THE PARTY OF
CORRUPTION.
>> Sean: MR. MAYOR, THE GUYS
NAME IS SHOW OPEN.
HE HAS SIGNED AN AFFIDAVIT ON
THREAT OF PERJURY.
HE ALREADY HAS.
WE KNOW, HE'S TALKED TO JOHN
SOLOMON, HE'S TALKED TO ADC
COMPANIES TALK TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
HERE'S WHAT WE DO KNOW.
THIS IS WHAT WE KNOW.
--
>> THE MAN IS AFRAID AND IF THIS
GUYS COOK IT, HE'S NOT GOOD AT
IT.
HE HAS A LITTLE COTTAGE, HE
DOESN'T HAVE A BIG FAMILY LIKE
THE PHONY PROSECUTOR THEY PUT ON
YESTERDAY.
HE HAS A LITTLE CAR AND HE
SCARED OUT OF HIS MIND BECAUSE
THESE PEOPLE THERE ARE DANGEROU
DANGEROUS.
>> Sean: WHY WOULD A
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA USE
THAT POWER, HE LITERALLY IS
SHAKING DOWN DEMANDING IN SIX
HOURS THE FIRING OF A UKRAINIAN
PROSECUTOR OR HE'S GOING TO
WITHHOLD TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND
USING OUR MONEY TO SHAKE THIS
GUY DOWN IN SIX HOURS.
EITHER FIRE HIM AND IT TURNS OUT
THIS GUY IS A GUY THAT'S
INVESTIGATING THE COMPANY THAT
IS PAYING HIS SON WHO SEEMINGLY
HAS NO EXPERIENCE WHATSOEVER,
ALL OF THESE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND I GUESS THE BIGGER QUESTION
HERE IS HE GOT AWAY WITH IT.
HOW DOES THE MEDIA SAY THAT IS
NOT A PAY FOR A PLACE SCHEME?
>> THE MOMENT YOU READ
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ARTICLE IN
2015 AND YOU SAW THAT BIDEN GOT
AWAY WITH HAVING HIS SON PULLING
DOWN MILLIONS FROM THE
CROOKEDEST OLIGARCH IN RUSSIA,
YOU KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
I PROSECUTED CORRUPTION.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
I CAN SMELL THIS.
OBAMA LET THIS HAPPEN.
WHEN THAT ARTICLE APPEARED IN
THE TIMES, ANY HONEST PRESIDENT
WHAT HAS CALLED THE
VICE PRESIDENT IN AND SAY JOE,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
I SENT YOU THERE TO STRAIGHTEN
OUT CORRUPTION AND YOU HAVE YOUR
SON WHO HAS NO CAPABILITIES
GETTING MILLIONS FROM A CROOK IN
THE UKRAINE WHERE THEY MAY HAVE
SAID BECAUSE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND ALL OF
THE SWAMP THE MEDIA ALLOW US TO
COMMIT CRIMES AND GO AFTER THE
THEY ARE NONSENSE, WE CAN GET
AWAY WITH IT.
I BELIEVE THAT'S TRUE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE ENABLERS.
THAT'S WHY YESTERDAY THEY
ACTUALLY PUT OUT A DOCUMENT
DEMANDING THAT THEIR
COCONSPIRATORS, THE PRESS,
SILENCE ME.
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
SILENCING ME?
BECAUSE I'M NOT MAKING ANY
POINTS?
THEY ARE SILENCING ME BECAUSE I
SHOWED UP WITH AN AFFIDAVIT
YESTERDAY AND AN ACCUSER WHO IS
WILLING TO STAND UP AND POINT
THE FINGER AT JOE BIDEN AND SAY
YOU ARE A CROOK.
I HAVE THE PROOF AND I HAVE THE
DOCUMENTS AND I'VE GOT --
THE WITNESS WILL SAY THE
COOPERATION BECAUSE THERE ARE
MORE WITNESSES WHERE HE CAME
FROM AND THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
ESCAPE THIS SEAN.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE FAIR
PEOPLE AND THEY DON'T LIKE WHAT
THEY SEE WHICH IS A FAMILY, THE
BIDEN FAMILY, THAT HAS BEEN
USING AS AN ASSET FOR
THEMSELVES, THIS PUBLIC OFFICE,
GOING BACK TO HIS BROTHER WHO
WAS SELLING HIS SON IN OFFICE
WHEN HE WAS A LOBBYIST IN
HEALTH CARE.
IT'S SCANDAL AFTER SCANDAL
COVERED UP BY A COMPLIANT
CROOKED PRESS.
>> Sean: WE WILL GET INTO THAT
ISSUE WITH THE HEALTH CARE AND
WE WILL ALSO GET INTO THE
BILLION CHINA DEAL.
WHAT YOU TESTIFIED --
BECAUSE I THINK JAY SEKULOW IS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO ANYTHING.
>> I DON'T KNOW APPEARED I'M
WEIGHING THE ALTERNATIVES.
ALL GO THROUGH IT.
I'LL GET MY EVIDENCE IN MY
CHART.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY WOULD LET
ME USE VIDEO TAPES AND TAPE
RECORDINGS THAT I HAVE.
IF THEY WILL LET ME GET SOME OF
THE EVIDENCE THAT I GATHERED AND
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, ALL OF THIS
NONSENSE ABOUT I'VE INTERFERED
WITH THE ELECTION, I GATHERED
ALL THIS EVIDENCE BEFORE THE
MOLAR PROBE ENDED SO IT WAS
CLEARLY UNDER MY RESPONSIBILITY
AS THE LAWYER FOR THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.